Senate Republicans as I said pass their
tax reform bill late Saturday night some
critics are slamming them for adding
lots of handwritten notes at the last
second to win over individual holdouts
like this is real a special tax break
for Betsy divorces college there that is
right there she wrote they wrote in a
special tax break for her college at the
last second well we looked into it there
are other last-minute additions to the
bill I think are equally suspect for
instance look at this the warmer parts
of Canada are now America look at it's
all dinner tables must include a setting
for Jesus there's this part anyone
buying more than two tubs of hummus will
be reported to the Department of
Homeland Security
probably smart check this one out
Hamilton must be played by a white actor
and the lyrics must be slowed down the
quarry vibrators are illegal in Utah
unless you promise you'll be thinking
about Orrin Hatch Mitch McConnell
directed that new frozen short so stop
saying mean things about it and finally
it life begins at insertion I thought
[Applause]
you